but when we were uh driving down the
street
in kentucky i see this bigger old dude
like dude i'm trying to make fun like it
would have took
he was moving at a snail's pace it would
have took him seven years to get home
and i made some joke and justin j are
laughing and they were staring i'm like
oh no i think something's wrong with him
and i seem like go like this bigger
like big dude yeah and then fall
[Applause]
so we go around the corner come back i
go you're right man his elbow's all
bloody yeah
and he's like oh yeah i'm okay he's and
i go
uh do you know what happened he's like i
just fell over
and i go what's not you don't look good
man you need some help and he goes well
i live
you know like a mile up the road i'm i'm
just walking i always walk every morning
because i haven't failed before and i go
uh but something's going on man goes oh
i had a stroke six months ago and it
paralyzed
the right side of my body so i'm just
trying to get out he went to walgreens
so i'm like okay he's like just help me
up my walk back like dude you're not
walking back
and like you don't remember falling he's
like no i'm like dude how about i give
you a ride
yeah and so i go he can't get up like
literally can't get up because his body
won't work
so i help him up shirt ruined just blood
blood all the time
he's getting up like this elbow in the
face
yeah and i was like okay okay yeah okay
and so we get them up
and then i go man i can be honest i
think we should uh call the cops
i think we should call the ambulance man
so he can get checked out because this
isn't normal
and he's he's from london he goes do not
do that don't do that
do not nobody call the cops i'm a
criminal and i'm like oh okay
yeah i thought that was a lot i'm like
okay and so i'm trying him up and then a
doctor who lives around the area pulls
up and goes
hey is he okay i go and he goes yes and
i look at the doc like this and goes
what happened he was i was walking funny
i see him all the time this is his route
and i go
yeah i get that's his route but i'm
telling him he was obese he's
big big he's not doing well man and he
was i'll be fine
just leave him like what the [ __ ]
wrong with people so i go dude i'm gonna
give you a ride back to your house so
justin's like damn man i go dude just
scoot over we'll put him in like
he can't really move he's like this like
yeah i was like this but as we're doing
that some
someone else drive by called the cops so
then i hear
sirens like a [ __ ] ambulance
fired
and we're supposed to go to lunch
everyone's starving i thought it'd be a
quick ordeal you know help him up keep
going
well no brennan two hours later because
cops blocked us in
ambulance shut down the street [ __ ]
fire ban
fire i'm like oh this is the whole scene
and then the guy looks at me while i'm
helping out goes
thanks man but i can tell he's not
genuine he's like thanks man
i don't want to make a big deal on this
i'm gonna be here all day i went oh
i thought i was here to save this yeah
but though so then the ambulance comes
and he and he refuses their help yeah
and the cop goes this happens man he's
alarmed by the
you know by all this and then i go all
right well we give him a ride he goes
we'll follow you just in case
i'm talking the cops all the cops came
to the show right they all come show but
i go drop them off and i go
you know something be like hey thanks a
lot man he goes all right yeah he tells
you to annoy because all the cops and
ambus came and he goes hey did you by
any chance find my um
apple earbud i go no where would i find
that billboard he goes
i dropped it back do you mind going back
there looking for it for me i want to be
like
hey bubba hey dude my entire day
has been [ __ ] ruined now man i'm not
caught
looking at you always wear that red the
white one ruined
blood all over it oh i'm the only one
with blood all over and now you're
picking through the grass because you
have to look
you kind of have when you wait look no
i was like uh i guess man jay goes man
[ __ ] this
and then the cop goes dude well handle
it you've done enough so the cops went
back and looked
and then when the cops came to the show
that night they're like we never found
it dude
he lost his [ __ ] earbuds yeah i saw a
guy that's scary though i saw a huge guy
die
right on that you know in the big quad
american he just was walking
and he had a sub sandwich i never forgot
he had a big stench
and he was probably 45 maybe 50
and just [ __ ] bob same thing in new
york boom fellow in
washington dc fell over on his back
dead and i i'm just going you didn't try
to do anything
usually i would try but somebody jumped
on him right away
and started helping him then another
person started helping him and then the
guy started trying to do
[ __ ] i remember just seeing him dead
with that with that giant
sub sandwich there and i i i remember
going
i'm not gonna eat subs anymore like i
saw the balloon yeah like
that maybe that's a bad idea i don't
know as we're pulling up jake goes what
the [ __ ] are you gonna do
i don't know do something and then i
gotta help him when i go i know cpr
so when you say stuff like that now did
i take a class for cpr yeah i did
was it 15 years ago yeah it was do i
kind of know what i'm doing
yeah yeah but doing cpr you can't kind
of figure it out you kind of gotta know
you know what the news
it changes up all the time but do you
know what the new thing was i know the
basics so
so so so tell me how you would do cpr
well for you listen for a breath first
and then um
you would i think it's it you blow and
you cover their nose and blow them to
their mouth
and then you do the pumps so now they
say don't blow in the mouth anymore
now all you do is you just keep the
pressure yeah you get one
now here's the now here's the problem
daddy here's the problem now while
you're doing this on the sternum are you
doing
them right remember you're breaking ribs
you couldn't and your boys think it
could be
yeah they do it all the time you know
now they have a machine that does it
but humans don't do it anymore wow you
know they have a machine that they just
put over your chest and it goes
really sick yeah yeah yeah it's it that
keeps your heart pumping you want to
keep blood flowing because now
apparently the oxygen oh what's your
blessing i didn't take it
when i uh when i worked at the daycare
yeah that's the machine right there it's
like 12 grand
now here's the problem when i did cp cpr
class not those chin those are shad
obviously not those though huh see that
one
see that dude i clicked on it it takes
you somewhere else
that's like that that thing for your
muscles but you just hit it and it and
it goes to work
how legit is that damn now would that
guy fit in that no
so we'll figure it out but the thing is
is when i was getting expands
uh yeah you think or you just like you
got to get it under him though you see
that you're not getting them no you need
all the power
i bet it i bet you can move it out i'm
not carrying that around how's that
like quick get the machine no but here's
the thing when i was doing cpr class
so they teach you you know the the mouth
and the chest but then they teach you
the heimlich
and so i didn't know anybody everybody
pairs up and then
they're like oh you're gonna pair up
with sarah i'm like where the [ __ ] sarah
well sarah was about 400 pounds yeah
that's tough
and they're like oh oh go ahead and get
behind and like oh this and the teacher
goes this would be good because you're a
bigger guy
dude i'm telling you i would i like i
was like [ __ ] yeah
it was it like yo dude if you girl if
you if you get a piece of steak down
your throat it's
it's gonna be it's time to go somebody
doesn't have an 82 inch reach no it's
getting yeah
unless dwight howard walks in right now
because i can't i'm telling you i was my
fingers
that's crazy yeah that's yeah because
that's [ __ ] anthony davis has given
you a heimlich i can't i saved a woman's
life
and a dog's life that way my own dog's
life but i saved a woman's life in a
restaurant
while on a date and and she was an older
woman
got behind her she was choking she did
the same she went and her friend who's
actually a famous actress olympia
dukakis goes
cat cat are you okay and i i go is she
choking but i'd save my dog like six
months before this way
i go she choking she goes i jump over
the
the i'm on a date i jump over the thing
i get in there
bop bop and she went yeah like that and
i saved it what was it
and the restaurant gave me here what was
it i'll give you did they comp your meal
they didn't call my meal unreal and it
was at ilbuco which is one of my
favorite restaurants
italian restaurant right one of the best
restaurants period and it was
god this was so long ago and they did
and i was talking to my girl this girl
who i ended up dating and living with
but
she said what would you have done if you
were on the airplane the hijacker you
know that and i
i said i would never say i would never
say what i do because i have no idea
what i do with an emergency
i want to sit there no i hope especially
now knowing how it ends right then that
happens
and i i remember it was olympia dukakis
because my girlfriend at the time she
was like that's my favorite actress
i bet you she jumped your bones dude she
called her sister and goes i i'm i'm
marrying this i'm marrying this man i
made this is captain i couldn't believe
that i was
who is she and then olympia caucus goes
like this she goes she's just
some old actress we don't yeah she won
an oscar for moonstruck it doesn't
matter it's my generation it's
1960. oh okay and she goes she looks at
me and she goes
right actress but she looks at me and
she goes i know
see you're new you're new to brian's
stories i just i was thinking nope
so like yep
i've ever had in my life she looked at
me she goes you were like a cat
the way you jumped over the over this
table you were a cat
and she went like this and hugged me did
you go no problem sweetie then it went
back to you i got embarrassed actually
caesar salad i'm a little embarrassed i
don't want to make it but everybody in
the restaurant
like that and then i laugh now hey i
remember i remember i was choking on uh
some
nachos from taco bell you remember just
the nacho cheese and the simple nachos
as a kid my dad i would get that and
churros the little churro sticks
and i had that and i was eating it i was
just starving i see it too fast and the
chip got stuck in my throat
and so it's me jay and my dad and we're
sitting there in the booth
and i'm just like my dad goes bren
you know and he's like bren and i'm like
brent i was like
nine or ten he was bren and then my face
started turned blue and i'm like
you know i'm going like this and my dad
goes he's choking and you know everybody
it's taco bell they're like all right
whatever man
and so my dad like like he didn't know
the heimlich so he took his
his [ __ ] dad big
dick beater that big dick beater of a
hand with his
[ __ ] oh he's missing yeah he's
missing this isn't it he's listening to
this
i was wondering why you were doing this
he's down two knocks he's down too
he's down two knucks so he's like he
took that [ __ ] hand
and just wow dude
i was like oh whoa now i have ct for
sure papa
whiplash it worked though yeah where did
he you know in the back he'd be square
in the back as hard as he can damn it
and it worked
my friend my friend told the story about
how he
he and this girl decided this is [ __ ]
he and a girl decided to do it like they
decided we're going to make this
work and she they had this long-distance
relationship they broke up
and there was tears and then he called
her and they had this come to jesus
moment they said let's
do this let's give this a shot give this
a shot like a love story and
she she uh was late to her flight
she made a meal she ate and she died
she knocked no she did she ate she she
choked on a piece of meat and died at
the [ __ ] kitchen table
alone in her house no heartbreak man
yeah what is that
story he told a story to a group of us
and he said the point is take your time
in life
i don't like the story man i don't like
the stories
i bet your friend was so fired up he's
like we're really doing this
here's the shot she's like cool let me
just make this roast beef sandwich i'll
be right there yeah how about my mother
buddy my other buddies dying of
pancreatic cancer right
and and and the the there's a terrible
story where his
buddy his childhood friend his son in
here are in the water in acapulco
yeah and a boat's coming and this guy
has his son and he throws his son his
little son out of the way and the boat
kills him right
and it was but he did this heroic thing
and saved his son yeah
terrible story but my friends dying of
pancreatic cancer and in the obituary
they write like you know it was such an
honor to
he loved he loved sam and he like he
mentioned how much he loved his friend
meaning his he was it was like a tribute
to also the fact that
in that game
but we did a podcast about it goes do
you know how you know how that feels
when you're mentioned in your friends oh
[ __ ] you're like you're going to so
obviously
see like basically was like see you soon
you did a month later by the way yeah my
friend yeah
how about me when your friend's dying
like that i was like you're going to
beat this dude
oh that's what we do [ __ ]
it is upstage of the lap factory right
away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son